my name is Jackie Earle Haley and I've
been nominated in the Supporting Actor
category was this a surprise it was it
you know it was I didn't sleep that
night before I knew there was a
possibility that maybe my name would
show up and sure enough in the morning
you know it was either gonna be there it
wasn't going to be there I had no idea
which it would be and it was just
amazing when it was there did the
telephone start ringing the telephone
has been ringing nonstop ever since it's
been great this is just so much I'm over
the moon this is the biggest thing
that's ever happened to me in my life
I'm songwriter dude this is amazing this
is it as far as songwriting goes I'm so
I'm so emotional about having been
nominated what your grandma's say I'm
pretty excited about being nominated you
know and it's pretty exciting to be be
with these guys because I like the
movies I like I like all the stories I
like the characters that play I think
they like have something to say so it's
kind of nice to be in a category where
all the movies have something to say
this is your first nomination yes it
must my first exciting and wonderful
nomination for the Oscar yeah
surprised yes surprised and and many
emotions and and like had dreams comes
through really really oh I won't cry
when I talk about this sorry sorry sorry
but this is amazing he sir
really a great thing for a Mexican
actress so tell me about getting
nominated this time it's always nice to
be nominated you never expected I've
been nominated 17 times now and how many
times 17 and it's never bad you know
it's always a nice nice feeling
I mean I've lost 16 times so well not
yet I haven't but I will have lost 16
times after this one and I never really
minded I like being nominated before you
were actually notified I guess it's that
how did you react on Tuesday morning it
was strange actually because right when
I I actually called my woman that I work
with to console her cuz I was you know I
thought if I hadn't gotten the call so I
figured that she'd be really upset and I
called her you know cuz I kept telling
it don't be disappointed it's not gonna
happen
and then I called her to make her feel
better about it and she was actually on
the line and anyway and she she heard
the news right then and then I heard
this like screeching and there was a
crash outside my my window and I went to
the window and this cop had been hit on
his bike and thrown like two blocks and
he was laying in the middle of the
street and then I'm fielding all these
congratulatory calls and I'm watching
this poor guy get put into an ambulance
and it was very strange but I heard he
only broke his leg so I guess it turned
out to be a pretty good day for the both
of us wasn't such a great day for him
really huh well I mean oh it could have
been worse there you go
but so you were really really surprised
yeah absolutely every time I think about
the nomination I think about all the
people that have you know believed in me
from the beginning and of course my
family as boring as that can sound but
it's just you know they didn't treat me
like I was crazy when I was 8 and I said
I want to be an actress and we didn't
even have a theater around our
neighborhood but my
but a huge better max video machine it
was so heavy so huge and thanks to that
I was able to rent movies I became
obsessed with movies I became obsessed
with Almodovar and that's what made me
dream about movies and now I can't
believe I got nominated for an Academy
Award I still can't completely believe
it
you